تقوم إسرائيل بتوسيع عمليتها البرية
لتشمل جميع أنحاء قطاع غزة، وتحذر المدنيين من
التحرك والإخلاء مرة أخرى بعد ثلاثة
أيام من القتال العنيف والضربات الجوية.
وتكثف الولايات المتحدة
تحذيراتها العلنية مع ارتفاع عدد القتلى إلى
أكثر من 15,000 وفقا
لسلطات حماس في غزة.  وشدد وزير الدفاع الأمريكي في غزة،
لويد أوستن، على
مسؤولية إسرائيل الأخلاقية عن حماية
المدنيين، وقال أيضًا إن ذلك يمكن أن يؤثر على
ساحة المعركة، كما ترى هذا النوع من القتال،
مركز الثقل هو
السكان المدنيون، وإذا دفعتهم إلى
أحضان العدو فإنك تحل محلهم.
نصر تكتيكي مع
هزيمة استراتيجية، نائبة الرئيس كامالا هاريس
ألقت بثقلها في قمة المناخ الثامنة والعشرين
في
دبي، وقد قُتل الكثير من الفلسطينيين الأبرياء
بصراحة، حجم
معاناة المدنيين، والصور ومقاطع
الفيديو القادمة من غزة مدمرة،
كما تشعر شبكة سي إن إن بالحزن للتقرير  أن ما لا يقل عن
تسعة أفراد من
عائلة زميلنا إبراهيم دي إتش مان قد
قُتلوا في غزة يوم أمس، فما هو
تأثير الولايات المتحدة في الوقت الذي
تسعى فيه إسرائيل إلى الانتقام من مذبحة
1200 شخص في 7 أكتوبر
وإزاحة حماس عن السلطة في غزة؟
استقال ضيفنا الأول هذه الليلة جوش بول
من وزارة الخارجية بعد فترة وجيزة من
7 تشرين الأول (أكتوبر) احتجاجًا على ما قاله عن عمليات
نقل الأسلحة الأمريكية إلى
إسرائيل دون فحص، وقال في خطاب استقالته إن
الرد الإسرائيلي واقتباس
الدعم الأمريكي لن يؤدي إلا إلى
معاناة أكثر وأعمق لإسرائيل.  كلا
الشعبين الإسرائيلي والفلسطيني، وليس في
المصلحة الأمريكية على المدى الطويل،
وينضم إلي جوش بول الآن، مرحبا بكم في
البرنامج، شكرا جزيلا لكم على
استضافتي،
لذلك أذهلتني ما
قاله وزير الدفاع الأمريكي، أعني أن هذا هو
تقييم عسكري جريء للغاية أن هذا
الكم من المدنيين أه القتل
لن يؤدي فقط إلى هذه المأساة التي
يشهدها العالم بل استراتيجي
استخدم كلمة هزيمة نعم وهكذا
أخبرني كيف تقيم ما قاله
أعتقد أنه  صحيح وأعتقد أن ما
ترونه هو توتر بين من
عمل منا أه في المجال السياسي والعسكري
أه على الأرض في الشرق
الأوسط أه وفي المؤسسة الدفاعية في القوات المسلحة
أه الذين
يفهمون أن هذا لن يحدث
العمل هذا لن يؤدي إلى
النتيجة التي تريدها إسرائيل فقط
سوف يطيل أه معاناة
الشعبين الإسرائيلي والفلسطيني لجيل آخر أه على
عكس ما أعتقد
وجهة نظر إيديولوجية سياسية للغاية أه
القادمة من  المستوى السياسي في
الولايات المتحدة وفي إسرائيل وفي المملكة المتحدة أه
الذي يعتقد أن هناك طريقة لإنجاح
هذا الأمر غير موجود والمعاناة التي
نراها على الأرض
تعكس حقًا أنني لا أستطيع تذكر وقت أه
في حياتي  لقد رأيت مثل هذا
الانفصال بين قيمنا
وأفعالنا أو بين وجهات نظر
قيادتنا السياسية
والحقائق على الأرض